There's a whole world inside of me
that's desperate to come out.
I found a way to communicate this world
through making jewellery.
For me, it is a language.
At first, I took small steps,
as this craft was completely new to me.
Eventually, I became more confident
in my ability to create,
an ability which
had always been there,
and I found a way to use my creativity
and discovered my own style.
I soon realised that the craft
of making jewellery,
was my calling.
Classical jewellery-making techniques
and traditional materials,
are still fashionable today.
But I'm most interested in using materials
that are not considered as precious.
I do like using metal,
but as a base material
which I build on top of,
with less conventional materials,
like resin.
The resin I have been using
in my recent work is so versatile;
I'm still discovering new ways
to using it.
All you need is patience,
and curiosity to discover
new ways of using the material,
in order to do things in a new way,
unique to your own craft.
I like to combine classical techniques
with techniques that evolve
from my own experimentation.
If I follow this method,
I know that whatever I create
will be a true and authentic
expression of myself,
resulting in jewellery that is unique.
In a fast-paced world
that's constantly changing,
it's hard to keep people's interest
with things that may be considered
old-fashioned.
But I think it is possible
to engage people with craft today.
If you re-imagine traditional techniques
and find innovative ways of working,
the designs will be both unique
and relevant for today.